yeah so this is a really interesting
puzzle
because it turns out the puzzle itself
is wrong so not only do you have to
solve the puzzle you have to figure out
what the puzzle really is
it combines two of my interests error
correction and sequences
so i found the sequence on a website
actually a dutch website
although that's irrelevant it's a
sequence that came up as part of a quiz
the quiz begins by asking you to
identify
various things looks like some kind of
uh
thing i know that word i know that word
vorwep
that means object aha the third page
has a number sequence on it and they ask
you
what's the number that goes where the
question mark is
and the sequence goes 1
2 6 21
85 question mark followed by 2586 now
you stare at this
and you cannot figure it out i didn't
see any pattern
so at the end you can look up the answer
and the answer they give is 430.
so you had to cheat to look up the
answer i cheated to look up the answer
because i couldn't figure it out and
since i am supposed to be an expert in
sequences i wanted to know
what is the sequence that i couldn't
figure out and once
i knew what they thought the answer was
i could figure it out
and so what they did
had a mistake in it how do you go from
six to twenty one
you add one and multiply by
three and we get twenty one so how do
you go from two to six
you add one and you multiply by two
add one you get three times two is six
how do you go from one to two you add
one a multiply by one
one plus one is two times one and you
get two okay
so so you stare at this and you say how
do you go from 21 to 85
well if you add one and multiply by 4
you do not get 85 you get 88
the person making up the test did it in
the wrong order
they multiplied by 4 to get 84
and they added 1 and they got 85.
how did they go from 85 to 430
they added one
to get 86 and multiplied by 5
and got 430. so they started doing it
right again they started doing it right
again
so that's the answer how long did it
take you to figure out what the mistake
they'd made was
well the pattern once you look at how
you might go
this is something you always do when
you're looking at a sequence and there's
no obvious
mathematical rule you say to yourself
how can i go
from two to six how do i go from six
to twenty one you try to think of a way
to build it up and well there's a
this part is one of many possibilities
but it works and so well all right then
it became clear that there was a mistake
it's one of the most basic things that
we can do and even now
even when we have digital uh images from
great big telescopes
we still get a lot of information by
looking at them with our eye